c'est un truc de ouf regard Jennifer
Lopez voilà c'est quoi leur secret c'est
la beauté augmentée en fait ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui tout à fait le chat
personnalisation experte beauté couture
ça veut dire aller dans le détail et
dans l'ultra personnalisation du soin
c'est vrai que les gens ne s'appliquent
plus simplement un cérémon ou une crème
il faut aller au delà c'est le fameux IN
OUT et donc on a besoin en plus de
l'application d'une crème topique on va
aller plus loin avec des device device
c'est des appareils cosmétiques qui
permettent de pulvériser ou par tout
autre diffusion de faire pénétrer le
produit bien plus en profondeur pour
avoir une réponse immédiate et donc en
fait ma signature c'est d'avoir un avant
après instantané dès lors qu'on va
rentrer dans une routine de soins vous
avez pas des avants
sur vous parce qu'en fait je vais je
vais faire des amis visages ça est là et
on verra un résultat un demi visage sur
nous sur nous par exemple
à travers le monde des nouvelles
techniques esthétiques des Appareils de
soins et celui-ci m'a pas mal bluffé
parce que je l'ai vu en Corée je sais
pas si vous savez mais la cosmétique
coréenne est vraiment dans la cosmétique
avancée dermatologue qui mettent au
point des formules rarissimes c'est
vraiment incroyable et donc c'est des
Cellules Souches Végétales et les
Cellules Souches Végétales en fait vont
au contact de nos propres cellules vont
revitaliser nos cellules les régénérer
et donc on est on rentre dans la beauté
régénérative
cet appareil qui est ici coûte moins
cher qu'un appareil cheveux
c'est 290 euros et donc avec ça on fait
quoi et après on fait on a des ampoules
de soins c'est quoi ça en fait et donc
on va aller
c'est tout à fait compatible même si on
a des injections on peut tout à fait ça
démarre maintenant
donc dans cet ampoule on active ici
puisque le principe c'est qu'il y a un
brevet quand même sur cette technologie
ou encore on va réactiver ou ça
c'est 4000 euros le flacon
en ligne et à l'Institut d'accord mais
sinon ça se trouve ça dans les ça se
trouve chez nous aujourd'hui
alors on commence
[Rires]
c'est un drainage lymphatique aérien
augmenter c'est incroyable ça sent bon
en tout cas
dites-nous votre santé
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans le drainage aérien vous connaissez
un peu les techniques de Kobido ou de
drainage lymphatique par manipulation
ici la manipulation il se fait par l'air
brush
ça dure combien cette connerie ça dure
combien
un peu moins de 10 minutes
[Musique]
c'est génial ça me rappelle ma Barbie 20
donc mettez des photos avant après
regardez tu rigoles mais tu es en train
de te lisse
franchement
l'idée on va lisser repulpé donc c'est
la pulvérisation de cellules sous
végétale pour faire ça combien de fois
par semaine
pendant le covid au moment où on a
effectivement fermé l'Institut les gens
se sont éliminés et en fait on avait
cette technologie à la maison cet
appareil et on fait des soins on les a
formés
tous les jours alors quand on est équipé
on peut on peut le faire comme une
application un sérum donc on peut le
faire un peu tous les jours mais quand
on fait un institut on peut venir une
fois par mois et ça tient
aujourd'hui il va avoir des effets
pendant une semaine où il va être
beaucoup plus à la fin de la journée
appuyer sur excusez-moi vous avez des
questions
est-ce qu'on peut se faire soi-même on a
besoin de quelqu'un pour lui
je peux voir
vous avez un côté globe
[Rires]
en grand soin sur une peau des métiers
mais on peut le faire aussi comme si sur
une peau qui est déjà incroyable et on
peut se faire soi-même mademoiselle bien
sûr d'accord je vais tout seul
[Rires]
de la personne j'imagine là vous avez
mis sur une ampoule qui est au lit one
c'est à dire qu'on a vraiment un
résultat sur tous types de peau
exactement on va même traiter des
problématiques profondes comme l'eczéma
l'acné le psoriasis puisqu'on va
vraiment jusque dans les cellules là
dans les cellules visiblement en fait ce
qui se passe c'est que on le voit de
façon globale mais c'est vrai que plus
on répète le soin et plus les résultats
vont être durables et s'installer dans
le temps on peut travailler sur les
tâches pigmentaires on va travailler sur
ah oui sur les faits vraiment
le pulvérise au niveau du scalp sur le
cuir chevelu on a des effets sur la
repousse des cheveux parce qu'en fait
quand on réactive les cellules du bulbe
on va réactiver la pousse on va ralentir
la chute et on le fait aussi sur le coup
le décodeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est très fort vous faudra que vous
reveniez parce que franchement c'est
incroyable ce que vous faites merci
Élodie parce que non vous voulez faire
le truc et vraiment on va revenir sur
toutes les stars plus tard parce que
voilà c'est vrai que on a pris du temps
pour faire le le truc mais donc ça pour
les téléspectateurs ça se trouve où ça
on va sur il le trouve il faut pas dire
les marques voilà donc voilà donc
d'accord donc ça il le trouve et c'est
pas très cher
plus durable sur le long temps sur le
long terme et avoir vraiment une
efficacité de soins remarquable et puis
en fait on a des soins professionnels
chez soi avec une facilité d'application
assez remarquable on vous fait une
démonstration on vous explique comment
on l'utilise il y a des vidéos aussi on
vous montre comment faire la routine de
soins et c'est vrai que c'est frappant
on a on a traité des gens sur sur de
l'acné sur des mélasma moi c'est vrai au
départ ma problématique de peau c'était
mais la SEMA eczéma j'avais une peau
catastrophique et c'est vrai que c'était
très complexée par un beau et en fait je
quand je suis allée en Corée je
cherchais vraiment des réponses à mes
problématiques mais finalement je
répondais à plein de choses